good afternoon everybody welcome back to
our retirement Commission
all right
um
we'll try and be efficient so you don't
lose too much of this beautiful day and
I'm glad to see that you're engaged in
the other important part of this
commission that is talking to each other
uh but first we have the minutes of the
two previous meetings which have been
posted on our website
and I'd like to have someone who has
read them make a motion to approve them
small group yes all right well someone
who who would be willing to approve the
matter
okay moved by Senator gray seconded by
Mr Martinez
any discussion Corrections
all right those in favor
aye aye those opposed
all right thank you very much the next
item we have is a
chart that from the retirement system
that is a summary of a number of
cost estimates that were prepared
earlier this year for bills under
consideration and uh
Mr Carlin if you would start to
introduce us to it and this is for our
information we don't
to understand some of the intricacies of
the way the retirement system works and
the way the costs vary
and so please do ask questions
thank you madam chair for the record
Marty Carlin with the New Hampshire
retirement system there are some extra
copies on the table or maybe everybody's
grabbed one already
um but we did we did provide an
electronic copy so that will probably
show up on the website
um what what this is is a a summary of
various bills and amendments that move
forward through the legislature
um you know this spring primarily
related to group two but there's some
group one benefit changes as well so
this is it this is a very
intense distillation of
some complicated legislation it's sort
of the the summary is is in shorthand so
there are some details missed but I've
got the the bill and the amendment
numbers if somebody wanted to dig deeper
um the second column is
u-a-l-u-a-a-l-m-pac that's the amount of
these changes that the actuary estimates
estimates would add to the unfunded
liability in terms of previously accrued
benefits that weren't funded you know
because they were being changed
um you know at this point
um the third column A projected employer
rate increase for police fire as a
percentage of covered payroll so
this is the
um you know what you know based uh what
the percentage increase would be for
future employer contribution rates
beginning in fiscal 26 which is the next
rate setting valuation if any of this
was passed
um you know this spring and then the
that those amounts in dollars you know
based on the current payroll data that
we have multiplied by those percentages
of pay
um finally members impacted is
um which group
um the benefit proposals would affect
we're using I'm in for this chart
because we have them now I'm using a 630
of 22 head counts
um the uh 1800 in trb that was um 630 of
21 head count so so there has been some
uh diminishment in that active
population
um you know you know in in that prior
fiscal year a couple of things to sort
of uh explain to the committee there are
some old hands who I apologize for kind
of stepping back but
um when we talk about employer
contribution rates there are two pieces
that go into that
um for the pension rate and that's the
unfunded cost and the normal cost and
the unfunded is the
um the liability
um piece that's that's paying for past
benefits earned but not yet fully funded
and then the normal cost is the actual
estimate of what it costs to fund these
benefits for these members going forward
so you know the normal cost is basically
a pre-funding between what the member
puts in and what the employer puts in
toward the normal cost
um if all assumptions are met that's
going to fund the benefit for that
person you know
um when they retire
um so there are
uh and I think the handout we uh dropped
off last week had showed what the normal
cost and the unfunded were and the
breakdown and most of what employers are
paying now is the unfunded piece
so the numbers in this chart are
um some of some of these proposals had
additional funding sources attached to
them so we we tease those out so these
are the raw unfunded if it was just
going to be paid for through future
employer rates with no additional
Appropriations or dedicated funding and
these are what the increases are in the
um employer rates associated with it
just to make it more apples to apples
um
so that's that's sort of the outline of
the the chart and again as the chair
said this is an intended you know uh to
you know pick an outcome uh but this is
just to kind of show the the the breadth
and the order of magnitude on what some
of the changes proposed in the spring
would cost so whatever this commission
mayor may not settle on recommending
you know this may help you without
waiting for the Actuarial assessment of
the proposals introduced by Senator
Bradley last week
um this this may give sort of a ballpark
or just just help you triangulate wrap
your head around uh the scope of some of
these changes
I I can go through each one if you want
or I can take questions whatever the the
will of the committee is
Senator Waters
thank you madam chair and thank you
um
could you point on this chart to the
ones that seem to be most relevant to
what Senator Bradley presented last week
yes
um probably the the
closest one and it isn't exactly that
close was um at the bottom of the front
page first page HB 449 this was a
proposal that was retained by housie DNA
and it increased the the multiplier for
service retirement for all members of
group two tier B and TRC going forward
on their for their first 20 years of
group two service so
um the Bradley amendments from last week
were based on a floor Amendment Senator
Susie had put together that we had no
time to analyze uh in time for the
Senate to vote on hb2 so we didn't look
at that's the closest one but we don't
have any numbers associated with that
one but this is the next closest one
this cost again this is all of tier B
which is what those bills contemplate at
a two and a half percent multiplier plus
tier C which are the current and future
group two members hired on or after
seven one of eleven plus future group to
hire so that this this is more expensive
than either of the Amendments uh Senator
Bradley put in and it would also be
harder to
terminally fund up front because there's
it's a in perpetuity there's you know
future members who aren't even in the
system we'd have to be trying to track
please
so I guess I'm hearing two things that
yes indeed I mean just looking at what's
here in that one you pointed to and
Senator Bradley said
um certainly the cost
would be lower because of the numbers
that he used for the autoplier and the
number of people including it but could
you expand a little bit more on the
second part of that about the um
is having trouble hearing you could you
bring your microphone closer
sure yeah um what I was trying to get at
is you know if if the change were only
for the trb group two people that's a
there's a finite pool of members in that
group so you it's easier to Value
because you know you you would apply the
assumptions applicable to that to that
group to come out with a cost but House
Bill 449 is introduced made that
multiplier two and a half percent for
the first 20 years for everyone so
somebody hired in 2030 2040 you know in
in the farther away you get it's it's
harder for an actuary to calculate
there's no liabilities associated with
those future hires but what the normal
cost is going to look like is harder to
Peg
but if I just McFarlane I mean that's
what I'm trying to get at is that I mean
we're going to talk about this more
later obviously but just to kind of have
a sense of it
um the terminal funding issue which is
going to be important for us could you
talk a bit more about the complications
of that part of it yeah so so terminal
funding the way it's used in retirement
um is you know the the concept of of
paying up front for
um you know a change so that there's no
rate you know there's no future increase
you know future impact on rates or on
funding so usually terminal funding when
I first got here was it was used in
mainly in the context of funding colas
if you know you know you're giving a one
and a half percent call to everyone in
2010 you know the actuary knows how many
people there are knows on average how
long they're going to live and what
their benefits are now so they can come
up with a number in today's dollars to
say you know that Cola costs 40 million
dollars or whatever
um obviously you know if there are
economic disruptions or other things you
know that it may not truly be terminally
funded but basically it's like that's
what it costs tomorrow to fund this for
everybody give us a check and it's done
you know so that that's how terminal
funding works so it works best with you
know in terms of getting truly accurate
estimates when you have a closed pool so
if there were changes just for trb and
we actually asked GRS in analyzing the
proposals from last week to come to
include a terminal funding number so
they wouldn't even have any rate impact
going forward it's like you know here's
the ual impact here's the rate impact if
you don't you know with or without
funding the unfunded piece up front
here's a terminal funding number for
that so we usually don't do that with
legislative analysis because when you
make open-ended changes for you know
current and future hires the the
degree of certainty gets gets harder you
know what I mean uh to to do so that's
that's terminal funding I hope that
answered the question the the other
point is that
if those changes are considered as an
improved pension for the people that are
currently in working and still to be
hired that increases the normal cost of
the pension and either the employer or
the employee will have to pay for it to
because it's an increased benefit you uh
you're correct Madam chair so yeah if
there's a benefit increase you know that
will
you know increase the normal cost going
forward
um for people you know and then the
member funds all all of the member
contributions go towards the normal cost
and I think
you know two percent two and a half
percent in group one and maybe seven
percent or so in group two employer
contributions fund that normal cost and
you know we we'll say sometimes you know
in the hypothetical perfect world we're
100 funded the the rates aren't onerous
for the member or the retiree to get a
decent benefit but we're not in that
hypothetical world we have a liability
that we're working towards
um you know uh
relieving uh you know over the next 20
plus years or so so
um you know so that that's that's how
that works with a with a closed group if
for the uh Bradley amendments from last
week if if since it is a finite nobody
nobody can be added to trb in the future
because they would have had to have
started between you know O2 and 2011.
um you know it you they they will try to
estimate a terminal funding for that
normal cost because they know you know
there's a beginning and an end point to
that active group
okay
does anyone else have any questions or
Mr real
thank you Mr Carlin
um so what
would it be safe to say that because
that is a finite group it has a has a
beginning and an end that this uh
projected employer rate increase for any
of those
any of the listed bills would eventually
decline or not be there
yes yes it's it's not a it wouldn't drop
off immediately the way that the normal
cost is constructed it's an aggregate of
all of the member tiers you know the the
tra the older members in both group one
and group two generally would have a
higher normal cost
um actually the newer hires in group one
are slightly higher than the middle tier
um just because of the demographics of
the people who've been hired in the last
10 years you know but over time because
the benefits are are lower for the
people hired after seven one of eleven
as they become
they're already the the primary amount
of people who are active now but when
they become the dominant and the full
amount of people active the normal cost
is going to keep going down to to fund
their benefits yeah
come on
Senator gray oh yes Senator thank you
thank you uh since my name is on the top
one on the system sheet
I at least want to talk to that one
it was a concept that that was discussed
in the Republican caucus and that's why
we asked for the estimates that you see
there
um I went through the transition for the
federal government in the 1980s and
early 90s where they went from the Civil
Service retirement system to the federal
employees retirement system
civil service retirement system was much
like the system we have here where there
was a defined contribution and the
benefits
or whatever
they went to a three-tier system
and part of that system was a smaller
retirement
social security and then a contribution
to the Thrift Savings Program
403 402 whichever you know term that you
you want to use for your your retirement
benefits up to five percent of your
salary and
so that this number that you see there
uh the 15.7 million is not a retroactive
number it would be something that would
affect all the employees group uh two
employees you know new ones old ones uh
whatever based on the percentages that
you see there
recognizes that that percentage does not
have to be the same uh throughout the
whole active career of the individual
that it can change one of the reasons
why
we looked at this was from the various
officers and stuff that came into my
office and said that we have a retention
problem that people now are looking at
going to Massachusetts or other places
to get to two and a half percent uh
after they get to their 20 years
investing
and certainly that can be solved by
changing the percentage and if that is
the reason that we're doing it is to to
do longevity and to keep the people
there then you can't just do the people
who are in that middle tier you've got
to continue that throughout if that's
what your intent is is to retain
employees past that 20-year mark uh now
that doesn't preclude uh the other thing
that I talked briefly about last time
and that is some kind of a matching
program uh which would be outside of the
retirement system uh and could be
negotiated with the various contracts
for uh the individuals so that if a
group comes in and says Okay I want a
five percent raise uh there may be a
negotiation that uh one percent or two
percent goes into match getting it up to
maybe a five percent match or something
uh you know maximum but that would be
paid with current dollars uh would not
have an impact on the the unfunded
accrued liability
it would be a impact on the local is
that if they negotiate the contract and
they negotiate that they will do this
match uh it will not have any impact on
the state and it won't be us
transferring anything cost to them
because they will have been The
Negotiator of that contract
and that on the state level certainly as
contracts get negotiated and that Clause
were in effect then the state would pick
those up as a regular cost of employment
and it would be outside the retirement
system so it it does a couple of things
you know it takes care of the people who
say I'm leaving because I'm not getting
the percentage I want now the percentage
that I put in there was 0.25 percent at
20 years and 0.25 more at 30 years those
were just
you know Place Keepers to start with
um
but you can see that that cost
is much reduced from some of the others
that you you see that are retroactive
and for this to be affordable and
sustainable
we need to look at that cost and make
sure that it is something that we can do
right now I've said it last time I'll
say it again uh I just don't see how
you've you fund
a cola that is Meaningful
okay
you know I'll sit here and listen to all
of you speak whoever wants to speak on
it but when you actually look at that
and the impact uh not in the first year
not in the fifth year in the tenth year
in the 20th year and whatever uh going
out because people are retiring and
living for many many many years
I mean who would think that I you know
would have been retired for 14 years
already
um but again you know some of those
things you know
if if the reason that we're doing this
is to retain are are qualified and you
know good individuals uh I don't see how
you just do that middle tier I don't you
know because you're going to run into
that same situation when you get further
out so again I just wanted to tell you
why this was done uh the reasons it was
done and the the thinking behind what we
were trying to do
thank you
Mr real
thank you madam chair
I was wondering if Mr Carlin might be
able to provide a little commentary on
uh the historical perspective of the
group one versus group two
classifications
um and I asked because it's it's my
understanding that those classifications
are in place due to the Hazardous nature
of group two jobs and whether or not
um as a short follow-up if you're seeing
many firefighters police officers and
Correctional Personnel working careers
uh in excess of 30 years if that's
common practice
uh thank you uh one of the uh one of the
handouts that
um was provided in advance of the
commission meeting I don't have it right
in front of me right now just so show
the average years of service
um for all four member groups when they
for people who go out on service
retirement which is the traditional path
to retirement you know not not a
disability uh retirement or vested
deferred and I if I recall correctly I
think the you know the average over the
last decade of police was 22 to 24 25
years and the fire was slightly higher
firefighters tend to work on average a
couple more years we you know we do have
I can I can get that from last year's
annual report the number of retirees in
each group who retired with more than 30
years of service I mean they're not
they're not
I don't then there are those people do
exist they're not in the majority
um but most people tend to make it a
career when when nhrs was created in uh
in 67 it was a consolidation of four
separate retirement plans for state
employees that had the option for some
towns to join police fire and teachers
so they all had their own plan
Provisions when they were drawn up they
all all of these plans were created
somewhere in the vicinity of you know
1938 to 42 you know given a ballpark
major Loomis is behind me he can correct
me if I'm way off on that
um but um you know so so they had
different benefit Provisions uh they
were they were put into nhrs as one plan
with one Board of Trustees and one trust
fund and you know there always were
differences between the group one and
group two benefits
um you know I I you know and it there
are probably two main reasons why is a
you know sort of the hazard the physical
toll and the hazard of the job in group
two and also the fact that group two
isn't in Social Security so you're not
accruing an additional retirement
benefit you know for your group two
service
historically I think that those are some
of the reasons of the you know the
difference in some of the formulas and
the retirement age eligibility issues
yes and from other bills that we've seen
over the last few years
the the federal government is not
letting anybody out that isn't already
exempt from Social Security to become so
so the teachers are going to keep paying
into Social Security
and the state employees are and if
you're smart the firemen and and police
won't
yeah Social Security was was it opt-in
for public employees uh it was uh I
think 1950 is when that enabling
legislation was passed by Congress so
States had the choice to opt in for
different Members New Hampshire for
whatever reason in the 50s chose not to
include Public Safety I think teachers
were added in 57 and employees right in
50 when it when it passed
okay
Mr real
Mr Carlin do you know uh once the
unfunded liability is paid off which
it's due to in 2039 if I'm not mistaken
uh what the actual costs to fund the
benefit would be
um if if um the the rate and in the in
the tail end of that side by side that
we dropped off last week it shows the
normal costs and unfunded liability so
basically what if there was no unfunded
liability and it was only the normal
cost then what what's left of a medical
subsidy amount at that point you would
just add those two numbers together and
just take the liability out of the
bottom line on the employer rates
um most of the liability is statutorily
required to be paid off by 2039
literally five billion of the current
5.69 billion there that would the uh
after the decennial commission met in 17
the legislature adopted a proposal the
commissioned recommended called layered
air and
so that's future gains and losses since
July 1 of 17 are paid off in 20-year
layers going forward so that creates
stability in the future like with with
layered amortization it would be very
hard if not impossible to get into the
whole New Hampshire gut in to win the
90s and early 2000s so the rates should
be stable for you know the foreseeable
future you know with with some
variations you know based on you know
economic Trends and things like that so
it's going to be a much less expensive
plan beginning you know in the 2040 2041
employer rates there still will be some
unfunded liability in those layers that
employers will be paying but it's not
nearly what they're paying now which is
75 to 85 percent of the total
contribution
um I just want to mention one other
thing about that and I'm losing losing
the thread unfortunately
um
one thing I'd like to mention is that I
believe there is a statutory provision
that if the employer rate drops below
the employee rate the employee rate is
adjusted down so that they're equal
that's what I was trying to remember
yeah because right now the employees are
paying the bulk of their re of their
retirement efforts and the towns are
paying off
the underfunding they imposed for 20
years yeah so currently the group one
rate is seven percent of pay for
employees and teachers group two it's
11.55 for police and 11.8 percent for
fire so if employer rates ever get in
each of the groups get below that number
the cost will go down for the you know
purport you know together in lockstep
for the member class
oops okay Senator gray uh should be
noted I believe in the percentages that
you gave for group one it does not
include their contribution towards
Social Security so yeah we we don't it
would be yeah they're actually paying 14
whatever uh compared to the group two
people who are paying
I haven't looked at my Pace though in a
while but I think it's 6.25 that the
employer and the employee pay into
Social Security
and then there's the Medicaid as well
and I think I think both groups in New
Hampshire do contribute towards Medicare
and are eligible for it since the 80s
uh one one thing I I thought to mention
I wanted to mention earlier is when
you're looking at this chart or even
some of the proposals that that may or
may not be sent out to the actuary be
careful you can't really sort of rack
and stack different proposals you know
oh if we take out this one piece you
know it's going to be cost this because
there's a lot of interplay between
average final compensation earnable
compensation multipliers you know it's
it's they're very hard to isolate on
their own because they're going to have
a cost effect on on things you know
outside of their immediate area so it is
a little more amorphous when you're
looking at costs would it be uh fair to
say that the difference between House
Bill 436 and and House Bill 2 which is
simply the inflation escalator implies
the inflation escalator was like 63
million yes exactly
which is a lot more than we thought it
was when we added it in yeah and I I
think I think the slight difference too
was that the
hb2 maybe it did but it like it also it
was the current law is 85 of your
average final compensation or 120k
whichever is lower and I didn't go into
100 fatigue so that had that added into
the 30 million but I couldn't tell you
how much but there was another another
you know sometimes sometimes things that
seem slight in normal discourse end up
being expensive you know when the
actuary gets their hands on them and
project it out as a monthly benefit
increase for somebody who's going to
live 30 or 40 more years hopefully you
know that you know
okay okay
it was from senator
Mr Carl and that uh 120 000 that you
mentioned or the the 100 or 85 depending
on what group you're in
um what understanding that there's no
definition for spiking with that uh be
considered in your opinion a spiking uh
preventer or an anti-spiking provision
I I wouldn't or nhrs wouldn't take a
position on you know whether you know
are not that spiky because there are a
lot of definitions but my understanding
is sort of the intent behind it when it
was originally put in in 2009 and then
modified in 11 was related to that you
know to that terminology thank you
Senator
um nhma testified that some of the costs
that were projected the last time uh
would actually be increased because that
the projections that you gave did not
include the cost that the local
governments would
um
have to bear based on those could could
you expand on that just a little bit so
that the people will understand what
they're talking about yeah when when you
talk about you know cost of all
employers including local government as
well as the state when when the employer
contribution rates increase you know
it's it's a percent of pay that the
employee the the employers are paying on
so
um you know if you're paying somebody a
hundred dollars and the rate was 20
percent you know and so you're putting
20 to sending twenty dollars to nhrs if
it went up to 22 percent you'd be paying
sending them 22 bucks and you know and
so on and so forth so the employer rates
the the with layer to amortization
changes like this to benefits are both
both in the the unfunded liability is
amortized over in one of those 20-year
layers so the rate increase is shown in
the chart include both the normal cost
and the unfunded piece for the for the
um for the
um you know for that benefit those
benefit changes after 20 years the
unfunded piece is going to be
um you know paid down so there's only
the future normal cost going forward
associated with it but
um you know and it's you know an actuary
wouldn't take those rate increases and
and roll them out 20 years based on
today's payroll because there are too
many variables to have a degree of
Actuarial certainty as a sort of an
exercise it's an illustration of what
the future cost could be you know but it
it's not
what the future cost will be it's just
one possible outcome I I you know if you
if you look at what the rates are now
and you're trying to project them out in
terms of dollars to Future employers
think of it as sort of a cone like you
know you're pretty sure what it's going
to cost next year and a little less sure
the year after that and the farther you
will outre get you know the the range of
outcomes gets larger with each year
because of all the other factors that we
don't have any control over
follow up
um but there is
um according to nhma a significant
amount that they would have to pay in
addition to the unfunded liability for
the proposal in house bill 2. uh from
the house yeah even with that 25 million
appropriation over 10 years
um you know there was still some
liability associated with that um with
that proposal plus the future normal
cost for those members so
um I think I think if I recall what Amy
and HMA did is took the rate projections
um you know from the fiscal note we
provided based on grs's analysis and and
rolled them forward 20 years and again I
it you can't say it's wrong or it's
right I did confirm GRS wouldn't be
comfortable telling somebody what it's
going to cost in 2038
um you know just just because of their
standards of practice but it's not you
know it's it's a it's a reasonable
exercise but it isn't
the be all and end all you know but but
it's fair to say that you know there
would be employers would be paying more
every year going forward under that
proposal the exact amount you know that
is is open to
you know interpretation or open to
whatever happens
thank you
Mr real
Mr Carlin in those projections that you
you're speaking about
um
unless I'm mistaken the overall rates
were still scheduled to decline as the
unfunded liability was paid down
um
we we ex well I mean the actuary I mean
in in the in the perfect world that
doesn't exist in a vacuum if all the
assumptions were
um the same uh were met you know over
the next 20 years that unfunded
percentage amount of the employer rate
should stay flat you will see some
decline decline in the normal cost as
you would referenced earlier so you know
and if investment performance is better
plan experiences favorable things like
that the unfunded percentage could go
down as well over the next 20 it's going
to go up or go down but you know we did
see a rate decrease
um 20 FY 24 25 versus 22-23 part of that
was the five years of investment
performance is leading into that rate
setting valuation you know exceeded our
assumed rate of return so if we
if we make more money than we expect
everybody wins essentially
um you know and if we don't you know
then then it would affect it so that
that's why they went down but it's not
like they went from
21 for teachers to 19 and a half from
ballparking here they're not going to go
down a you know 18 and a half 17 and a
half I mean they're going to you know go
down much in a much smaller Pace from
the normal cost but they you know they
they're not expected to go up
uh should again you know if our
assumptions are reasonable and uh they
should go down somewhat over time you
know maybe 20 38 when the big slug is
paid off there should be a noticeable
decrease provided the legislature
doesn't go berserk and start adding in
more benefits yeah there's a rate Cliff
like 20 39 to 40 that most of that
unfunded is gonna go that they're paying
now is going to go away they're going to
see a huge
um drop presumably at that point based
on the projections Mr Garland thank you
again uh the as the New Hampshire
retirement system met its assumptions
over the five-year 10-year 25-year
averages
um over the
you know it I I want I don't want to say
yes or no not because I don't know but
because the assumptions do change over
time we do what what are called
experiences study experience studies
every four to five years and things like
mortality tables
um the investment return assumption
changes so you know basically our
current under our current assumptions
it's a six and three quarter
um investment return for the year that's
probably the biggest factor in all the
assumptions is how much how do we do in
the markets and we have exceeded that
over the three five and ten year periods
and I think over the 20 or 25 one of
those two as well so you know
you know we when we had an eight eight
and a half percent investment assumption
back in the early 2000s for for a number
of reasons you know I'm not sure if we
were all performing that you know
historically but we're outperforming the
current assumptions or meeting them
Mr Fuller oh thank you I just wanted to
go back to actually something that
Senator gray had mentioned before about
um colas I know it's not really on this
um sheet if you will but I was wondering
if the retirement sister is has actually
costed out what a reestablishment of a
cola would be because uh well I agree
with them that I'm sure it would be a
fair amount of money but I think it
would be maybe useful and if you've
already done it that'd be useful to have
that information sure
um it's it's dated information but the
decennial commission uh did they they
had an appropriation for their work in
2017 and they asked the um askgrs to uh
cost out a a permanent ongoing caller of
I forget the percentage
um you know going forward and you know
because it's a permanent compounded
benefit increase every year I do recall
it was in excess of a billion on the
unfunded liability I can pull those
pages out and send them to to be
distributed to the commission that's
based on the assumptions we had in 2017
so there may be some variation
um more recently the only actual
permanent Cola that the legislature
passed was in 2018 effective in fiscal
20. that was a one and a half percent
for all members on their retired more
than five years on their first fifty
thousand of retirement income so so
there was some exclusions on that one
and that in in for to terminally fund
that amount that Cola in in that
legislative session the actuary
estimated about 70 71 million dollars
you know to pay that increase for life
to everyone who'd be getting it
um that Cola the actually the
legislature chose not to terminally fund
it they passed that on in employer
contribution rate increases I think they
were like somewhere in the you know
point two zero zero point two percent
increase or what it wasn't you know it's
all relative but in terms of the
percentage increase on the current rates
it wasn't a huge percentage increase but
it was passed along
to the state and local employers so
there are different ways to fund that
and that was I think pretty sure that
was too
2018 and then effective
seven one of 20.
Mr real
Mr Carlin are you familiar with uh
whether or not there are other New
England states that have Cola formulas
in place and if not is that information
we might be able to get
I I
think some do I believe Maine does for
instance I don't have numbers on that
but it's accessible information there's
a a group The National Association of
retirement system administrators
um Nazareth that does a lot of uh data
compilation they they partner with a few
other people on the public pension
database and they have a grid multi-page
grid of colas
um you know that I can I can obtain and
provide for the commission or if you
just want New England states like
thank you uh Mr Greenland will also be
working on that with you so if you'd get
together sure
I'm sure that'll be of interest all
right so it sounds like no one has any
specific questions about these these
proposals is that true
so where did we're drifting off into
brainstorming on what else we can do
with the with the commission so
thank you Mr Carlin thank you
all right so the obvious issue is
cost of living increases
which is something that keeps coming up
and
it's as you've noticed we've been
talking about it and I'd like to comment
that that a cost of living increase is
not a feature of a defined benefit plan
a defined benefit plan guarantees you a
benefit
and doesn't include any increases
so we're talking about trying to
add on to the basic plan a feature
another feature that's not really
compatible with it
so anyone else Mr Martinez
thank you madam chair
uh could you tell us where you got that
from that a caller is not part of
defined benefits plan it's the def it's
the definition of a defined benefit it's
defined when you retire you're given so
much percentage times your years of
service times your final pay and I
happen to have two defined benefit
pensions myself and I am
will confidently bet real money that I'm
never going to get any increase in
either of them
if I may follow up is that that some
patients their defined benefit don't
have a caller or you're saying that this
specific definition doesn't allow for a
caller because that sounds new to me I
never considered that
is it normal to find benefit
plan is as I said designed to provide a
defined benefit so you know for sure how
much you're going to get you don't have
to worry about it going down
but you also
don't have to worry about it going up
either
that's that's an extra
thank you I believe that when the
legislature created outpatient in 1967
there is a abundant evidence that they
always intended that Cola was part of it
it provided Cola from 1967
on forward paid by the general fund
in 1983 the legislature created the
special accounts that paid callers for a
period of an entire almost three decades
28 years of performance
work has taken the job performing in
their you know position at work
expecting the call and being paid the
caller that was drastically stopped in
2011 without any provision to uh
continue that so it is a fact that the
legislature has not made a law I Define
definition or contribution of a cola in
the system because none was needed
we provided the colon now we know that
this special account was not a perfect
vehicle it had its problems but like any
other vehicle that's not perfect you
either fix it or replace it you don't
stop driving which apparently is what we
did we stopped providing the cola
altogether which became a real problem
for workers that live in a very short
budget say for instance the average
retirement for group one is in the 22
000 something like that
and that became very difficult so a
caller it's not so much a luxury like
going in a cruise that you only go if
you can afford but it's more like a
necessity of life whether you buy food
medication pay your oil Bill and that's
the category that we look at the cola so
I think that I asked this commission to
take a good look at ways to return to
what the patient was intended to be and
provide a cold benefit to both group one
and two
and uh and return to what we meant
you know you thank you okay Mr real
thank you madam chair
um while I don't necessarily disagree
with your
um
your your definition of a defined
benefit plan I think
with all due respect to where we're all
sitting here because many of us that had
a defined benefit
um wasn't didn't in fact end up being
defined it was changed and I think if
that benefit was changed in in one
regard
um then it could potentially be changed
the other way so I I would like to not
dismiss any of these ideas on their
surface and continue to discuss uh the
potential for for all benefit changes
that are going to be positive that's
true exactly for Senator Gray
um
trying to think outside the box when it
comes to Kohl's
one of the options though when I retired
from the federal government is to take
the money that was
deposited in my Thrift Savings Account
and buying an annuity and one of the
options in that annuity could be
that it be
A reduced annuity but have a cola built
into it from the insurance company
certainly people who don't get to
retirement age can withdraw money and
again I don't know you know how that
could fit or if it would ever fit but it
is that kind of thinking that we need to
do if you're trying to come up with a
way to fund some kind of a cola it might
be through an insurance policy where
instead of getting X you get x minus
something to start with and then the
insurance company you know does the the
call afterward again not throwing that
out as a proposal but throwing it out
you know so that you guys can start
thinking about it to see if if there's
anything in there that that could be
done uh certainly
you know I I understand that you know
especially in periods of high inflation
as we've had for the last couple of
years that it becomes very very
difficult uh to live on my hundred
dollar a year you know legislative
salary but uh but I I may make it work
so
Senator Waters
thank you madam chair so we're kind of
related to
Senator Gray's remarks just now did you
turn your mic on please sorry it's kind
of related to Senator Gray's remarks
right now and then to remarks he made a
little bit earlier
um I wanted us to kind of revisit as I
mentioned last time what we discussed in
the 2018 sorry
um final report and so what I did is I
had the uh discussion of the um
public and employee Deferred
Compensation Plan the 457b
that we undertook during the San Diego
retirement commission and a motion that
was brought forward by representative
McGuire and myself
at that time to move to an opt out
rather than opt-in program
and part of our thinking of that time
was that this this came upon the
um you know after as part of the
discussion about the colas and
recognizing at that point in time
because of the billion dollars that
those figures that we had that would
there be another way to
help people in the future ensure against
um
you know the difficulties of uh
inflation and in a sense I looked at
that time as the of the 457b is in a
sense of vehicle for people to fund
their own colas and um so we broadcast
this proposal that failed in the 7-7
motion but it said that there would be
um an an opt out rather than opt in on
the 457b and that there would be an
escalation over time of the amount as
the salary went up that went into that
program
and that that would that would be a way
of essentially supplementing by
providing something that could in a
sense provide a you know deal respond to
the inflationary pressures over a period
of time
um
and at that point in time there were a
few place a few states that were
starting to move towards uh opt out
and um since that time uh this has been
done more and more I think most
comprehensively in California but of
course the state is funding that part of
that um which we're probably or may not
do but I think that the um you know the
opt out and even some of the statistics
here that we got back in 2018 about the
retention of people who had opt out
instead of opt-in meant that most you
know most employees really saw this as a
as a good hedge against the the future
so I just thought I I want us to bring
it back back in and um Madam chair since
you spearheaded this I thought maybe
there's some things to say about it but
it does provide us with another option
if we can't get to
um the cola I had a build in 2021
that house bill 1563 that implemented
um
this plan
and
it died in committee because there was
no enthusiasm from anybody except myself
in the 457 plan and we and I couldn't
see
mandating that people join into it
if they didn't appear to be interested
and their the employer wasn't interested
the unions weren't interested and no
employees seemed to to be interested so
uh I gave up at that point
but if you're interested that's that's
the description of the plan that's House
Bill 1563 of 2021.
Mr real
thank you madam chair thank you Senator
waters for this proposal
um I I guess I do have some reservations
with it I know that public employees
have the opportunity to participate in
uh
deferred compensation plans currently
and I think that when we we look at two
things first we look at public employees
now coming on to the job uh don't do not
receive a medical subsidy will not
receive a medical subsidy in retirement
um so many are utilizing their current
457 simply to fund their health
insurance at retirement
um I I can speak for many of the folks
that I work with if that's what they're
using that for currently and that's not
accounting for inflation and the cost of
of just simply living in retirement so
I'm while I appreciate uh the Senate
behind this I'm not sure that that would
cover what we're looking to accomplish
the other thing that I think is worth
looking at is in the 2007 decennial
report they recommended a two percent
increase on employee rates to fund
self-fund a cola those rates were in in
fact increased by about two percent but
those colas were never funded so I think
it might be worthwhile looking at
why that that money was redirected or
for lack of a better term I should say
why it was used on something else
thank you
um for for those points and uh
I guess my kind of question
for you Mr rule in a way was that given
the earlier comments by Senator gray
that if we had
some more you know
if we look more to the 457b at one and
what it can do or could do I mean you
mentioned the health benefits and that's
important thing but you know over time
if these are invested in the market that
you
you know over time might if let's just
say it's the the rate that we're making
assumptions there that that is going to
over 20 years mean something maybe even
beyond the health insurance but I think
that the other possibility as you
mentioned you know would there be a
possible employer match and then you
know Senator gray raised the issue about
maybe it would be part of a vocal
contract negotiation now when I was in
the Union at UNH my employment there
these kinds of issues were part of our
you know collective bargaining whereby
we decided you know with their the
report to take you know do something
different with raises because of health
benefit
um contributions and retirement benefits
contributions so I mean I think that
some things can come into play
through a focus on a force 57b I mean I
hear you and I hear the the chairs
saying you know Box come at us into
there at all you you shout it out nobody
nobody responds I guess is the message
in that but um I I seen what other
states are doing with this
and the success and that the opt-in you
know may be a whole lot of maybe a
formula for later regrets that's all
thank you yeah and
I I've yes Miss Campo
let's see Kathy Stacy so I I do
appreciate the uh 457 I think that it's
been very useful I know that I have a
lot of Staff who work for me who will
participate
wholeheartedly in this and I think it we
don't want to foreclose tools in the
toolbox and I think something like this
is a is is a good tool and we should
really think about it thank you
nope one the the other method of
providing a cola is what we've been
doing for at least the last 15 years is
somebody comes in brings in a bill and
asks the legislature to approve it and
we fund as much as we think we can
afford from the budget that year which
which was actually what was done in the
60s and 70s we took what we
the the retirees asked for an increase
in the legislature said well we can
afford
this much and we'll give it to you which
is
which has been known to work Mr Martinez
thank you madam chair I believe that uh
in my mind and I think a lot of workers
that we think a good Cola benefits would
be one that is aligned with the Social
Security Administration coales so say
for instance the Social Security gives a
one percent caller that's what we do
they give half percent that's what we do
no then none three then three and that
way it would save the legislature so
much time that you can use for other
things and other bills and all the other
stuff that we have to do for the states
and uh I think it'll be a win-win for
everybody it would be good for workers
good for employers it would be good for
the state economy because that money is
going to go right back into the economy
trust me that not a thing is going to be
saved and shipped away
so that's something that I'd like us
take a look at in other states that do
that or if they don't we should be the
first New Hampshire again to align our
call a benefit with the Social Security
benefits
and if we Define that on the RSA it will
be unmistakably stated and won't have
any problems okay thank you
anyone else
representative leishman
thank you madam chair and maybe you
discussed this before I arrived so I
apologize for perhaps asking the
question but one of the things that
brought us here was the Senate's
rejection of House Bill 436 that as you
worked very hard on in your committee
and finance division one in particular
worked very hard on and came up to a
bipartisan solution which was rejected
by the senate in House Bill 2 is it your
intention to look at say 436 is you know
Finance retained that bill
um the
that's one way to implement something
early next year would be to modify 436
and send it in from Finance
but the
um we are currently costing out two
options for The Gap people and we're not
we're currently sort of brainstorming
what longer term or what more widespread
changes we might want to consider
for the retirement system because
there's
the the Gap group is a current problem
that we're trying to solve but our chart
the charge of this commission is broader
than that we should look at overall do
we want to make changes to the
retirement system and if so what what
are they and how would we decide if
they're worthwhile
yeah I read our charts I just recently
looked at them again and I it
letter b
um I thought that this 436 would kind of
fall into that charge that looking at
you know not only the Gap but other
issues but I think considerable progress
was made last year during the budget
process or this year during the budget
process to address the Gap and I'd like
to see that as a strong position of this
commission to come out with a strong
recommendation to deal with those nearly
800.
um
I'd like to present to the commission
that we have more than one option to
change the law the first one is that the
commission can make a recommendation we
introduce a bill that would be
in which would be introduced in January
and sent to committee detail cost and
if we're lucky passed in June
we also have bills in
fine house finance and house Edna that
could be used to make changes if they
are agreed by the commission the the
each committee could recommend it out of
the 436 out of Finance uh I forget what
the number is that I've got
uh 449
we could amend that either of those
bills to do whatever we thought was
appropriate from the commission and send
it to the house floor in January
that would be the fastest way to do it
or if we know exactly what we want we
could submit it in September
each legislature legislator can submit a
bill in September but I think the
commission itself will be
would be better served by amending one
of the retained bills those will be
later
okay
anyone else want to speak on oncolas or
just the
are there any other concerns that
we want to make sure are considered
I'd like to mention that we
ought to look very hard at how we're
funding the retirement system because
right now
most of the changes we make get flowed
directly down to the property taxpayers
and
that's
that's a concern of a lot of my
constituents and I'm sure we all pay our
own property taxes
so I'd like
I'd like to to if we make changes to
seriously consider funding them
from the state rather than slowing it
down into the employer rates
yes Mr Martinez thank you for bringing
this subject up
as a long time resident of the State of
New Hampshire I noticed that our
property tax have been infected a lot by
that and I'll say the most significant
and effective way to reduce our tax
rates
would be if the state returned to pay a
portion of the cost of the teachers
firefighters and police officers
retirement
as you know in 1977
we were paying 40 of the cost for the
teachers and it was reduced to 35
percent in 1977 when we also picked up
the cost for police officers and
firefighters at 35 percent so we're
paying 35 percent for teachers police
firefighters and police officers this
was a good move because it allowed the
tax rate to be less properties were
lower in price
rents were affordable
and communities didn't have to
really go through what we're going today
to make all the payments and I'll make
ends meets but I'll say this another
reason is that this is a common good
families are allowed to travel move from
north south west to east so it can move
from one part of the state another
you could have an increase to your
public schools unannounced and you have
to provide that education same thing
with the fire events all the towns come
in to help same thing with the police
event so it's a common good that can be
shared with the state furthermore the
state have other Pockets where to get
that money from like the federal
government grants and many other types
of a system while citizen Town only have
one main source of income and that is
your wallet in mind and and that's how
it is so I strongly encourage that and I
think to start we should consider at
minimum of 10 of that cost for uh all
these groups to be paid by the state
to decision balance employers thank you
Senator Greg
um
a question on that suggestion are you
suggesting that we actually go back to
what we were paying way back when and
reduce the amount that we're getting in
Roman Mills tax that we have increased
and reduced the amount that we're paying
to the cities and towns in Rhoden Bridge
there's a whole bunch of other things
that we increased
okay
or we wouldn't you know are you
suggesting that we decrease those so
that we can go back and increase you
know the thing that you're asking for
again I'm looking for balance I'm
looking for fairness okay thank you
clarify what I'm suggesting
yes please no we're not suggesting that
uh there's no really no really need to
pitch like rooms and meals against you
know profit taxes or the towns and all
this this is something that we should
suggests they say that we should look
seriously into that because I think it's
accomplishable we did this before at a
much higher rates when we had a lot less
income the state has ways and means that
you can get that cities and towns are
not equipped for that tiny little towns
all they have is a bill and a few
taxpayers will make ends meet it's very
difficult so I I say about my suggestion
thank you madam chair now
anyone Mr real thank you madam chair and
I appreciate
um your thoughts behind uh how we
continue to fund retirement in the
future I think
um you know going back to what
representative leishman was speaking of
um with House Bill 436 and the
provisions of that that did come with a
proposed funding mechanism and I think
it'd be worthwhile as we look forward to
um
improving some of these benefits within
this commission to consider that as a
funding source which was the
communications tax okay
Senator Waters
thank you madam chair um
an issue that I I we did talk about a
little bit last time on the multiplier
was looking at it
um it beyond what was included
in Bradley's amendments and we had some
discussion
um at that time about whether or not
this the speaker and the president
in terms of what they're willing to fund
for Equatorial studies would be able to
look at the issue raised about
um
looking at the multiplier for beyond
what we was being looked at in those um
in the broadly amendments and I think
that got kind of left hanging because we
did vote as a commission to just fund
the uh Actuarial on on the two Bradley
amendments so I um I do think that if
Senator Susie were here she'd certainly
be raised in that issue about should we
look at the multiplier more broadly and
so I just didn't know where we were on
that and how we might study it and you
know whether
um the speaker and the president were
amenable I mean we had a little
discussion about last time about if
we're extending that the reason that we
sent those
um
plans from Senator Bradley to the
actuaries is that we were considering
adopting them
very quickly if we were to make a change
to the multiplier long term that would
be presumably be in a bill and you could
use some of these as you know
suggestions on how much it would cost
but we'd get the analysis as part of the
bill thank you and that that thanks for
reminding me that makes sense so I guess
that
my point being this is that if we're
looking at our in our conversation now
uh things that might become part of our
recommendations of the commission I
guess that I would put that one out
there that you know maybe looking at
and potential legislation about the
multiplier might be something we would
discuss as a possible recommendation of
the commission as we move forward
okay so that would be multiplier for
group two or group group one as well
I'm trying to recall a conversation from
last time because I didn't see it in the
minutes but I know that Senator Susie
did bring it up but I think it was for
the rest of uh group two as I as I
recall okay
anyone else have a an issue they want to
bring up is it Mr Earl thank you madam
chair
um are we still in the spirit of uh of
brainstorming a long-term issues okay I
don't want to muddy the waters here but
um I think you know one of the things
that that came up during discussions for
House Bill 436 was the concern about the
ability to spike one's pension in final
years of service which I think
um
by and large uh most of us agree that
for the for the health of the retirement
system in the long term
um sustainability of it that spiking is
is not something that we want to see
occur again but one of the things that I
want to talk about
is how uh
around our Recruitment and Retention
issue we're forcing many employees to
have to work extra hours spend extra
time
um you know on the job in order to fill
vacancies that the municipalities are
unable to fill with new recruits
um and and in order to do that we're
having to pay uh our current
employees overtime to fill these shifts
and in many cases they're being forced
to work those shifts you you heard of
the issues we're having in our state
prisons and
um having the National Guard having to
staff those positions uh speaking with
Mr Campo earlier he was talking about
how the state troopers are uh
inching closer and closer to about 75
vacancies which is concerning so when we
talk about trying to fill these
these positions with current staff in in
forcing our current employees to work
we're talking about a significant level
of burnout
versus the uh what is the actual
incentive to remain on the job and one
of the things that we're currently doing
that was changed in 2011
is we're carving out the overtime
compensation and we're calculating it
differently than we did prior to 2011.
now prior to 2011 uh one's overtime was
calculated as base pay along with about
15 other uh things uh and in 2011 that
was pulled out and calculated as
compensation over base
now I understand the concerns of spiking
but these are actual hours worked these
are these are hours that employees are
actually present and accounted for and
working and in many cases as I mentioned
forced to be there and I think we should
take a deep look at those overtime hours
as as being calculated as part of the
base pay once again which
I think is is reasonable when you look
at all the provisions of House Bill 436
to pull that one out
it quite simply it passes the straight
face test to take a look at that so
okay
yeah I think that
um
restricting overtime beyond what one
worked throughout your career
was the intent of house bill of the
changes in 2011 because there are people
that work significant amounts of
overtime
from day one and and but it is possible
to choose to work overtime in your final
year just had your pension
which that's the definition of spiking
but if it's mandatory over time I think
we ought to look very hard at like you
say at including that in base pay
thank you
um and I and I was certain that that uh
this would be a part of the conversation
and just as
um to add a little bit more context
there are other anti-spiking Provisions
that exist that would uh currently
limit that from happening for example in
the final 12 months earnable
compensation is limited to 150 percent
of the previous 12 months
uh unused sick and vacation time is not
calculated as earnable comp
the calculations are averaged over five
years not three
um in in many cases I would say most I'm
not I'm unaware of a municipality uh
that doesn't regulate spiking in one
area or another for instance over time
at least for for firefighters uh has to
be at least offered in a fair and
Equitable manner
throughout its Personnel so it prevents
the opportunity for one individual from
spiking their pension and another
individual from getting none
all right well we'll take to keep that
as an item any other issues that need to
be brought up
Mr Fuller yes
yeah and if I can just add on to that
because I think you definitely Mr rule
makes some really good points with the
overtime payment so it doesn't really
affect our group
um but I think look bringing back some
of those end of career payments but
again just also emphasizing wanting to
manage this the whole spiking thing and
not looking to obviously have someone
obviously dramatically increase their
pay is definitely uh I mean that's it's
not it's not fair it's not right but
um I know it was something that I know
at the very least in group two our group
for instance used to be able to have
some end of career payments that I know
they used to be credited I know they
were ceased in 2011 so it would be good
to see some of those come back but again
in a reasonable form if you will so
definitely with some
safeguards if you will yeah the trouble
the trouble with the spiking is that if
you're working overtime throughout your
career the
that's built in if you're final year or
years are a lot bigger than your
previous years you haven't paid into the
system because the estimates are
are such that you'll you'll get a
certain
pay increase over your career and if you
suddenly jerk up the last few years your
pension is increased but the payments
into the system aren't
they they're
nope nope they're definitely a fair
point it just had some other thoughts
too actually I had some uh
some thoughts written down I'll pass
them around so might be easier people
want to okay take a look anyways
um
the colas I know we've already um talked
about um actually if anybody I have some
extra comparisons to other other states
for for that and for some other things
that people wanted I have those over
here people wanted more information
about that but again just some other
just kind of brainstorming ideas if you
will
um you know just highlight here a couple
of not just reading the page but um more
for more for our group looking into
we'll expand the uh eligibility for to
um support staff and I see a real
benefit in that because then that way
there will be more employees actually
paying into the system so kind of
referring to your last comment about the
concern about not paying into the system
which is a fair point on your part so
you'd actually increase the amount of
people that are actually paying in the
system so naturally there'll be more
people that will be eligible for some
kind of benefit as well I know but again
I think the more people that actually
pay into the system I think would make
it a healthier system so just one
thought one thought there
um
just looking at the benefit calculations
again going referring back to 2011 I
know that it was a change from the
highest three to the highest some five
for um for um both tiers so it would be
nice to be able to again for attraction
and retention it would be nice to be
able to again bring that down to the
highest um three
um
it would be something too that it would
be you know it would not be an immediate
Spike if you will but it'll be something
that could be prepared for so you know
kind of like you know factor in over uh
several amount of years
um potentially looking to change the uh
that I know our vesting period right now
is 10 years so
um competing states like Vermont and
Maine for instance and again I have that
more in my other things over here they
actually have um it being five years and
I know it was mentioned by someone I
pardon me I forget who but uh there's a
real concern about losing our Public
Service
um folks to other states so I think
bringing in line our system to more of
the benefits offered by other states is
something that we should definitely
consider because uh we definitely don't
want to lose our police flyer teachers
whatever else to other um States because
I mean you know they're not going out to
California person but I mean you could
definitely see someone moving to mass or
Vermont
if you will if it's going to be that
much of a difference
and then the last thing I think I I
think I already mentioned just like the
additional longevity payments I think I
already mentioned that you'll just again
some some thoughts and one thing that's
not on here that I'll just kind of throw
in just sometimes thoughts kind of enter
the head if you will
um going back to the increase whereas I
know uh Mr Carlin who was talking
um mentioned how the payments going from
um up two percent for everybody else I
mean
employees have been now paying that
extra two percent now for the last 12
years
so if you will so what are some things
if you will whether it be like
pre-funding a cola whether it be either
in pre-funding a medical
um payment I know a medical subsidy
payment that we had several years ago so
knowing that those things are kind of
have already been pre-funded for quite
some time so therefore the money would
already be in there and at least that
way to the employee would actually be
getting something extra for that two
percent that they've been paying in I
think that would be a really nice way to
look at um attraction and attention of
um our valuable set employees that's all
I had on that okay thank you
senator
if I could respond to that um
in terms of the the first issue brought
up about the the colas um
and I I wondered um you know the this
Prospect here of saying if we have a
coal account
and understanding the problem with the
funding of colas that would we be able
to look at in a sense a proposal that
kind of holds at some point in the
future time kind of level what the
contributions are from the
municipalities I suppose
so that instead of the decline that
funding might go into this account
and I I didn't know if you know Mr
Carlin might be able to comment as to
given what you said about the slowness
of any eventual decline if you have any
kind of
you know just off the cuff thoughts
about this kind of concept
yeah I mean if you see the proposal here
in one one way I read it is to say that
at a future point in time
that if we set up a cola account
that as the amount as the unfunded
reliability starts to decline and
therefore the
employer contribution rate for that
unfined liability starts to decline then
would that
employer contribution if it were held
steady or a part of it was the decline
were slowed so that that funding might
go into this special account I mean
isn't that more or less what your you
know kind of implication would just
suggest you Mr Fuller something along
that line something along those lines
yeah I think you definitely have the
idea there okay thank you
if if uh you know the the the the real
world problem right now is the unfunded
percentage is so high that you know you
know and if we waited until 20 alleged
the legislature you know collectively we
the state waited till 2040 there's a
generation of people who are working now
who wouldn't benefit from that if if the
rates were lower and there was a
legislation you know there was a law
pass that
um you know Porter they have the
employers pay the actuarily determined
contribution rate plus X you know with X
going into an account dedicated towards
colas I mean you it you know it could
work in theory that the the issue too
then is if you start that in you know
2024 or 2044 do people who were working
before that date available for those
callers or are they left out in the cold
you know there's there's a there's a lot
of practical inflammation implications
but the in the short term it's just it's
you know the you know what the rates
such as they are now and that's you know
that you know that's a policy decision
to you to
put in a you know actually determine
rate plus X you know you know that that
becomes a special account you know we it
was a term
um you refer to as the special account
there used to be such an account and it
didn't work that way it worked kind of
in the opposite
um where it essentially skimmed off
investment earnings over some percentage
of the assumed rate of return and put it
over in this pocket and said coal is a
medical subsidy which is great if you're
always making more than you think you're
gonna make which means probably means
you're you're not is too low to begin
with but you know but what happens is if
you have a down year or a negative
return you have no money to backfill it
on the pension side because this money
money is Promised for something else but
you're
your proposal as I understand it would
would not do that it would be over and
above so it's not going to shortchange
the pension benefit side of the the
trust
thank you
Mr real
uh thank you madam chair well we still
have Mr Carlin at the mic uh one of the
things that Mr filler had mentioned was
the vesting period
Mr Carlin
I the way I understand it in in current
statue
it speaks of vesting but is there an
actual definition in place for what
vesting is now
term wise
yeah I'm not I'm not entirely sure
because because it was by reference
um you know there's a type of retirement
benefit called vested deferred
retirement which says that if you have
10 years of service and you terminate
your employment you can come back and
collect their retirement benefit based
on those 10 years uh I'm I I'm actually
not sure we may or may not have added a
term in 100 A1 for vesting
um I don't have the law book in front of
me but you know that that was always the
you know it wasn't a reach I mean it was
you know legally you know there was a
solid ground to consider vesting for 10
years but New Hampshire at 10 years many
states even had three year investing and
they've increased it to five ten is
still on the high side nationally for
investing period
great thank you if we could Madam chair
I'd like to add that to the the
conversations for the future
just defining what our vesting period
should be thank you and if I may well
I'm still sitting here just for the sake
of
folks who haven't been living in this
when we talk about vesting that means
you've earned a right to a future
pension benefit it doesn't mean you can
collect you know five years I mean if
you're 28 years old and you hit your
five years you still have to be a
certain age to collect your benefit it's
just when you become eligible for that
ultimate benefit
yes
um
before you leave uh what
do you expect that we'll have the
results back from the actuaries by next
week thank you madam chair I wanted to
try to work that in my first go around
up here we sent that off to the actuary
this week and
um We believe We will have the analysis
of those two bills prior to the meeting
in two weeks uh nine seven so uh when
once we have them and look them over
we'll get them over to you to distribute
and then we can
um you know be on hand to discuss
okay
I just want to say that the discussion
with regards to keeping the employer's
share going is of concern to me because
as a town official
I know that we obviously have to pay
towards the U hey Al and that was what
that extra money was for it was not for
funding anything else but that ual so I
have concerns about the discussion about
leaving that the employer's share flat
so that we continue to pay now it's
going to be for Cola
mm-hmm
that's that's a very important political
point that if we choose to create and
fund a cola who has the fun of paying
for it
the employer or the employees or both Mr
Martin thank you madam chair
um I like to ask if we could get
the the value of how much have we
collected for the two percent including
Investments since 2011.
and I think that number may be readily
available and I'll say why
as you heard Senator Bradley said that
whenever we propose a bill they do a
estimation cost so in 2011 there was an
article by the Portsmouth Herald that
quoted this honorable Senator that he
said
and uh that the estimated
the estimated gain would be 750 million
dollars
and it's on that Arc in 2011. in in The
Herald
Charles McMahon May 18 2011. now the
economy did a lot better than we first
estimated
so that number might be close to a
billion dollars
as you see the retirement system had a
real hard time 2007 and eight because we
had a bear Market the cost of the value
of SP 500 would declined to 50 so we
made a lot of drastic changes and fixes
temper a permanent fix to temporary
problem the economy rebounds after that
and the retirement system if you looked
at it on this chart that we received
from the retirement system is continuing
to grow from 4 6 7 8 9 10 billion so
we're over 11 billion now regardless of
the fact that some of our investment
returns were not that great they do a
great job at this fantastic job but the
Investments are very unpredictable we
had a great year in 2001 at 21 bed 2022
minus six the three times continue to do
that and that's basically when you
collect two percent extra with no extra
benefits and you invest that money and
we've been doing this for since 2011 a
good 12 years so we had that study back
then
we had to had otherwise like the senator
said we wouldn't have had that bill so
if we could get that to the group so we
can take a look at what number is that
we collected in addition when we start
collecting two percent more from
everybody for 12 years in a row I think
would be helpful
thank you madam thank you
anybody else
all right it seems like we've run out of
inspiration
uh if we don't have the Actuarial data
on for two weeks I'm going to suggest we
cancel next week's meeting and re we
meet in two weeks
so that we can
um
look at the numbers for this the short
term fix
and I and I thank you Mr Fuller for for
providing a nice summary I
um
I think that we might want to have
another discussion on on
call it the the question really is not
whether we want to give them it's
how do we pay for them and who pays
so but which is an important discussion
so we'll do that
all right
yes some question Madam chair so I I
agree I think that'd be a good idea
um I really like the idea of canceling
the meeting too by the way but um
um I I just wondered you know what your
kind of thoughts were yes we've
generated a lot of ideas I think Cole
was obviously rise up up there but um
you know I just wondered what you
thought would be helpful how we think
about all the things that have come up
today for our meetings moving forward I
think summer ones we may actually want
to make a recommendation on some
probably don't and of course any
legislator can put in a bill
um so I just wonder what you thought
would be how you thought it's going to
be useful
plus to go through this list or maybe we
can talk about it when we next meet but
I think we ought to talk we ought to
think about it and talk to talk to our
constituents and see what other issues
we might want to do and
um
and as I said we've got different ways
to incorporate these ideas into into the
law so it we should consider what kind
of a
of a bill would you want to submit and
would it be
something we'd want to vote on in the
house or the senate in January or just
introduce it then I mean that's we have
we have options
well and just if I may I mean kind of
part of my point is to say that I think
that what we end up making as
recommendations from this body will
influence that and also lend a certain
weight that we have considered in a you
know in the context of a broad-based
commission what yeah are areas that it
looks like there might be some
opportunity to move forward form on a in
a consensual basis so well that's uh
we've got some some ideas we don't have
a a firm plan that we could consider and
vote on saying is this something because
the commission as a whole wants to
recommend so
it's we all can work on on generating a
a more solid plan that would be
wonderful Mr real thank you madam chair
uh one of the things I just want to draw
further attention to and representative
Leachman brought it up
um that
that this commission was developed as an
amendment to House Bill 436 which was
um very defined in what its scope was
now obviously the scope of the
commission as written has expanded and
that's great
um I think a broader discussion on
retirement benefits as a whole for
everyone is warranted but I also don't
want to shift Focus away from why this
commission initially was established to
to
fix or repair benefits loss from groups
in 2011 so if we could just also keep
that in mind that would be appreciated
I'm I'm sure we're going to have at
least two outputs one one short term and
one longer term or maybe two or three
longer term
anyone else have a comment
hey thank you all for coming we will
take off
next week and resume re-meet on the 7th
of September
thank you